So one of the reasons is that by nature
women
are normally more than men. That's the
reason you find more widowers
more widows in the world than widowers.
The woman without husband that husband
has died is much more than a man whose
wife has died because the life
expectancy of a woman is much more.
This is not the only this is one of the
major reason that women are more in
number. This is not the only reason why
Islam allows a man to have more than one
wife.
There are many other reasons. I'll just
touch on few of them. For example, after
a man marries, he realizes that his wife
is
she can't give birth to children.
So if both want children and both agree
the wife can no problem since we don't
have children I wouldn't mind my husband
marry again the woman so that we have
children or hypothetically even if the
wife doesn't want so the only option for
the man is that he either gives divorce
to his wife and marry a new wife or
keeps his first wife marry the second
wife gives the first wife a due rights
and marry their second wife and have
children. Which is better? What is the
fault of the woman if she's sterile? In
other religions, you have to divorce
her. Alas, in Islam,
if your wife is sterile, it is not a
sin. It is something which is bad. What
you do? You keep your first wife, marry
a second wife, give equality to both the
wives, give respect both the wives, take
care of both the wives and have
children.
Let me give you another reason. Maybe a
man marries, a young man marries a young
woman
and within a couple of years there's an
accident and in the accident the wife
she finds herself that she cannot do the
duties of her wife because of the
accident. She cannot do the duty of her
wife to the husband because of accident.
She cannot take care of the children.
So what to do now?
Two options. Either he divorces the man.
Either either the man divorces the wife
who had accident and marries a new wife
or keeps her marry another woman. That
woman takes care of the children, takes
care of him
and both are happy.
Which is better? What is the fault of
the woman if she has an accident?
What is the fault? Nothing. Anyone can
have accident. Let me give you one more
reason. Or maybe the wife has some
terminal illness.
In the terminal illness, she cannot take
care of the children. She cannot take
care of the husband. What can he do? He
either divorces her and marry the new
wife or he keep the first wife and marry
the second wife.